المسافه بين واشنطن وبيكن تقلصت حراره
اللقاء كانت بحجم القضايا الخلافيه بين
البلدين الجليد الذي طالم ميز العلاقات
بين الصين والولايات المتحده على مدى
السنوات للعقود الماضيه بدا يذوب بلقاء
تقابل فيه بعيدا وشي جيمنج الى طاوله
المحادثات عوض اطلاق التصريحات الناريه
ايضا تحدث بلغه طبعها الدفع وكان اللقاء
يجمعه بزعيم غربي من حلفاء واشنطن
التقليدينا نتشاركوا المسؤوليه في اظهار
ان الصين والولايات المتحده يمكنهما اداره
الخلافات بينهما ومنع المنافسه من ان
تتحول الى الصراع وايجاد طرق للعمل معا
بشان القضايا العالميه الملحه التي تتطلب
منا تعاونا متبادلا
الزعيم الصيني رد التحيه باحسن منها بل
عبر عن تطلعه للعمل مع الولايات المتحده
لاعاده العلاقات الى الطريق الصحيح
لتبادل الاراء معكم حول مسائل ذات اهميه
استراتيجيه في العلاقات بين الصين
والولايات المتحده والمسائل الاقليميه
والدوليه التطلعه للعمل معكم سيد الرئيس
لاعاده علاقتنا الى الطريق المستقر من اجل
مصلحتنا ومصلحه العالم
لقاء مثل نقطه فارقه في العلاقات بين
بلدين طالما خاض حروب بارده خفيه احيانا
ومعلنه في حي اخرى موعد قد يشكل نقطه تحول
في مسار الصراع الذي اتخذ ابعاده عسكريه
واقتصاديه ملفات مختلفه تلبد سماء
العلاقات بين البلدين قد تنقشعوا سحبها في
المستقبل ان لم يكن اللقاء مجرد سحابه سيف
عابره بلال الوجداني العربيه